For 13 years, you didn't just deny it;...
...you brazenly and defiantly denied everything you just admitted just now.
So, why now admit it?
That's the best question.
It's the most logical question.
I don't know that I have a great answer.
I will start my answer by saying that this is too late.
It's too late for probably most people,...
...and that's my fault.
I viewed this situation as one big lie that I repeated a lot of times,...
...and as you said, it wasn't as if I just said no and I moved off it.
Right, you were defiant.
Oh yes.
You called other people liars.
I understand that.
And while I've lived through this process,...
...especially the last two years; one year, six months; two, three months,...
...I know the truth.
The truth isn't what was out there.
The truth isn't what I said.
And now, it's gone.
This story was so perfect for so long.
And I mean that, as I try to take myself out of the situation and I look at it.
You overcome the disease,...
...you win the Tour de France seven times.
You have a happy marriage, you have children.
I mean, it's just this mythic, perfect story,...
Yes.
...and it wasn't true.
And that wasn't true.
And that was not true on a lot of levels.